I am Jammu and from France and my field
is laser
[Music]
well I think I always believed that you
know signs you know try to unify I mean
should be used actually to unify people
and and I'm a strong believer in this
and it's like music you know and
everybody speaks the same language and
signs the same thing in science we all
speak the same language you know and we
work on the same problems and we try to
make this world better
[Music]
well the passion of light in fact comes
from the laser the first time I've seen
the lasers I say wow couldn't believe
you know what to see this lights so
well-behaved this beam of light you know
various kind of pure colors and so on
but was very captivating for me kept me
on going for 45 years
[Music]
yeah of course you know the combination
of Gallia you know as a physicist is
winning the Nobel Prize and then when
you get this phone call from Stockholm I
knew of course by the Nobel Prize for
Physics is always given on the first
Tuesday of October and and before before
noon you know so and I was kind of you
know waiting you know waiting even if I
had the small chance you know was keen
on waiting and also interested to know
who was going to get it but anyway I'm
having Schwimmer
so I was on my way to go to the swimming
pool and my my circulatory just where
that means a jock could he come back
yeah we have a phone call for you from
Sweden you know from Stockholm Hawks
they go maybe that proved yet and so we
kept the phone and of course it was
coming from Stockholm you know and so I
almost crashed because it's so data
night when you hear it and by change in
bad change your life also
[Music]
always has been extremely wouldn't one
thing I've done we haven't invented a
new type of laser with Donna Strickland
my Colo in it and we invited of letters
and in a process of aligning the laser
my student not Donna but never student
got the beam in his eyes and so we took
the students it was not wearing goggles
like he was supposed to but you know
accident happen and so we took him to
the hospital where he's not a
neurologist you know and there are
technologists look in his eyes his
retina and so on and he said hmm yeah he
got the laser in your in your eye in the
retina you already nice bone but he said
but what type of laser is it and the
student said you know told him but it
was a new type of resin say and he asked
him why are you asking this questions
well because you the damage you have in
your eye is perfect and that you know
started what now is femtosecond
ophthalmology there is millions of
people now were using the femtosecond
laser for surgery you know so it was
very clearly a mistake you know it was
not playing at all we better open up
completely
you feel and you have millions of people
who are benefiting from from this
application now
[Music]
this is very close to my heart all the
energy on your mental issue I will say
is unlike to top you know of my of my
[Music]
occupations because we see everyday of
course you know that of course we are
science brings a lot of goth technology
brings technology no so but now it is
science
I invented if I'm in fact new terms for
this type of science should be toilet
science do you understand
toilet science now because some signs
some of the signs you know help to
destroy the planet with all the
technology but cannot part so we should
really know things about really cleaning
the mess basically which has been done
we have to say that you know the
consequence of some there's new science
in technology
I would say yes we have to be very
careful about what we do I think it's of
course you you know you have science
Sciences and when you have a technology
engineers and technologies and then you
have products and so on and then
consumers and so on so I think for
scientists we really need to discover
work on improving training the planets
don't some in nuclear power for instance
you know nuclear powers we have all this
nuclear waste so we we working you know
with lasers on trying to basically
improve the situation because nuclear
energy is certainly a very you know very
important source of energy which could
be very clean at one condition we have
to clean up the West after that so if we
come up with reasonable solutions to
clean up the West then when one will be
fantastic
[Music]
well the scope for lasers in is enormous
its enormous okay you know
in 1960 the laser was demonstrated by
ten Mayman but it was invented by towns
and as soon as the laser was invented
people were saying you know what's going
to be the use of his laser so they try
to find applications you know for the
lasers it try to find application in
fact when we also demonstrated a very
high high intensity lasers but we got to
prize for also we want to share about
the applications and nowadays they well
we have cost enormous amount of
applications you know and what I like of
course is applications in the medical in
medicine and so on that it would be very
very important on the top of my agenda
[Music]
my I think I have only one advice for
really students who would like ready to
get into science and research and all
that you have to be passionate if you
don't if you are not passionate about it
you know you should do something else
has to come from out of you because it's
very hard you know it's very hard for
you but also for me also I have to say
for my family because you are always
thinking about your research because you
are passionate so you are thinking only
but one thing you know and so some some
some time is stuff for for the people
work with you you know I mean the type
of laminate type of quality you need you
know of course is ability to enjoy you
know being long time in the lab and be
the be patient and obstinate we focused
oh my swimming is very important
I'm swinging well I'm skill you know I
was born in the French Alps you know
this town musical name and their will
and where we got the Olympic Games and
and so skiing doing is basically a
natural thing for me but also I love
swimming swimming for me it's like yoga
you know you it's a very peaceful you
know I'm I'm talking about open water
swimming okay and I love that
[Music]
that's right and I have a problem
because when I think about this when I
think about because I'm feeling your
inner state when you're swimming your
honor state of yeah you are relaxed
totally relaxed but also you're thinking
about the research and that's a problem
because sometimes I forget the number of
laps I'm doing you know well you know I
because my dad was in working in the
electrical power companies you know in
the ABS functional and so it was always
we were always at always talking about
current power and perth voltage and
things like you know we had that
transformers and all that because this
is what he was doing and I was in a way
and I was always explaining to me how
they were working with my dad playing
chess and doing
I mean learning about physics yes
yeah you know I mean working with
graduate student is like with your
family being with reading your family I
mean that's the way I always traded my
students we with Tara labs together with
discussing we you know we can switch
spend together and so on I mean always
thinking about what we want to achieve
and and that planes bring the students
and the faculty together you know then
we are aging you know the faculty is
aging but we were nude you know students
are nude and so we always close to the
very very young student and I'm very
pleased also that many of my students a
few of my well many you know got ten
will be attending to the Nobel lectures
and so on events
[Music]
since the very beginning I was very
attracted by 22 to really produce very
very short pulses short pulses in at the
beginning it was the peak of Saigon and
then femtosecond and then at to second
and so on so picasa gone is 10-12 you
know is one thousands of billions of a
second and pickles were Gandhi is
fantasy Gandhi's urn of billions of
millions of a second okay and I was
always fascinated by what we could do
because it's it's you could really do
for that we could really for the first
time we could you could see things
moving in this time scales and of course
we are not moving in this time scale but
molecules atoms electrons and all that
they move in this time scale and of
course your eye is too slow you know to
follow them so trying to understand the
world with this new tool with tool of
having very short pulses so you can
track down you know the evolutions of a
very small systems to understand
reactions and that this is really
extremely fascinating then came the
second applications and the second
application is if you are producing this
very very short pulses then you can
produce if you are smart you can produce
very very high intensity very high peak
power and this is where we are the
problem with Donna is fact because the
power but you because the pauses are
short so power what we are trying to get
can be very high but
at one point you are breaking down the
laser because the power the peak power
is too high and that's of a clamp clamp
down the laser power but we can produce
and it's where we come came up with
Donna with this idea of CPA which it
chirp pause amplification which could
circumvent these problems of the laser
being destroyed as we were amplifying
the pawns getting more big power my
Nobel prizes was awarded you know
because of my work with laser with very
very short tours laser and why do you
what why do you want to appear in like
very short pulse lasers is because these
pulses will be also important for
communications very important for
telecom for communication in general
very important also in a medical world
very important for many of disciplines
and because because with these very
short pulses you would be able really to
to observe or to track down you know
reactions which happen in cells but also
which may happen also in a transistor
for instance you know for communication
fast electronics and so on and also
because it will be is a bi-racial person
gives you the ability to produce over
very short times extremely high peak
power so we can use that for nuclear
physics and maybe also try to understand
events which are happening in the cosmos
because you can reproduce the highest
temperature so highest pressure so
highest field so highest
garetty so you can you can release with
simulate and bring back into the lab
what is happening in the cosmos and in
life you know
[Music]